the uk government has come under fire
for promising to provide more than a
billion dollars of funding to a
liquefied natural gas project in
mozambique a group of climate scientists
say providing that funding is
incompatible with climate targets and
that undermines the uk's global
leadership on climate change but the
government argues that gas has a vital
role to play in a clean energy
transition so vicky first of all what do
you think about the uk
continuing to support
projects like this abroad we'll talk
abroad first before we talk domestically
do you think it's a good idea
well this particular one of course if
you think about the liquefied natural
gas it's quite useful has been very
useful in the uk recently has been
useful in europe and it will be quite
useful in asia where it's meant to be
going from mozambique because of course
when you look at what's happening with
coal-fired power stations and coal
produced considerably more and in fact
produce something like 45 more than uh
gas so gas as a transition
um product if you like is in fact very
useful particularly for developing
countries where the investment that
would need to be made otherwise is
beyond their means
right now okay so what do you make
you're well you're shaking your head
donnica do you not agree with that then
well to be investing billions globally
in new fossil fuels when we've got nine
years to get to net zero is is insanity
the recent research in the in the
journal nature said we need to leave 60
60 of existing gas in the ground if
we're going to have just a 50 chance of
not breaching 1.5 degrees centigrade so
britain should be doing is investing in
enabling developing countries go to
directly to renewables rather than
making them dependent on new fossil fuel
investment and we have to remember the
investment in mozambique it's a tiny
fraction of what britain's investing
globally it's just not 0.1
over the next 10 years british banks
government and oil companies are
proposing to invest 750 billion in new
fossil fuels including glass it's
untenable
what about domestically then vicky i
know that shell
talked last week about the the need for
continued investment in oil and gas they
say it's critical to the country's
energy security what about the uk
i think up to a point that's true uh but
of course what needs to happen is it
should go hand in hand with carbon
capture and storage and i think that's
the development that we need to see
happening i know it's been talked about
for quite some time so far it hasn't
been developed to scale but i think it
can and the right investment will make
quite a bit difference there so for the
time being i think the transition period
is such that if we don't have enough
security of supply here we will see the
the types of increases in prices we've
seen very recently and which of course
will turn the consumers you know off the
whole idea of climate change if it's not
done properly so yes i think some
balance uh in the development is
absolutely essential but i don't
disagree that we need to get to the
right end uh you know when we look at
what is required in terms of climate
change measures both mitigation and also
adaptation and donor the uk government
says there's likely to be an ongoing but
diminishing demand for oil and gas that
the uk couldn't commit to phasing out
the energy sources entirely for now do
you think that's a fair position
um
nobody's talking about phasing out um
oil and gas immediately what we're
talking about is a transition over maybe
a decade what we are talking about is
stop investing in new fossil fuels we
have more than enough gas to to burn the
planet with more than enough gold oil so
investing
five trillion dollars over the next 10
years in new fossil fuels which is
government supporting through the
through our banks etc it doesn't make
any sense so that's the situation we
have to do is stop the new investment in
fossil fuels and actually invest the 5
trillion in renewables for both uk and
foreign developing countries
you